hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the finals of the London
chest classic this is the final leg of
the grand chest tour and we have the
final istikhara Nakamura and Maxime
bashira Grove in the semifinals of the
the London chess classic you've seen
that Nakamura knocked out Fabiana for
wanna well not knocked out but Caruana
is no longer in the run for first place
and maxime beaugeois Grove has defeated
Lebanon so now Corona and Aragon are
battling it off for the third and fourth
place our is here we have a Nakamura and
the maxim going at it for first place
and the to classical games were drawn
then they played to rapid games the to
rapid games were also drawn and now they
have to play four blades games three of
the first blitz games were drawn and now
this is the fourth game I'm showing you
it's really a very nice game they've
already used this line twice in their
match
but then Nakamura looked something a
little something up and decided to mix
the things up so let's see how it went
in this game Nakamura has the white
pieces so all of the previous game
between Hikaru and the Maxime in this
event have been wrong let's see how this
game went Knight to f3
we had the ready opening c5 c4 Knight to
f6 and knife to c3 so doing was opening
is on the board the symmetrical
variation and the Maxime goes for d5 as
in the previous two games they played C
captures Knight captures we have e3
Knight captures and c3b captures in c3
and g6 now preparing to be in care of
the dark square bishop and we have
Bishop to b5 check by Hikaru
Bishop to d7 blocking and here Hikaru
saw that he said that he between games
he checked on the computer and that
Bishop to e2 was very nice for white so
he decided to try this out and it you
know playing complete game it really
doesn't help if you don't know this line
so you do have to play something
original with black so Maxime simply
continued developing and that's the
correct weight way to go Bishop to g7
Hikaru castles and maxeen castles and
here we have d4 and okay Bishop to c6
now taking control of this very nice
diagonal
Bishop to a three now going after the c5
pawn and here
we have si capture Sundy for this
position was already reached in 2015
between a lauren and threatened a and
Dion upon me ah she where b6 was played
and that game were ended in a row but
here we have C capture Sundy for we have
C capture something for and now rook to
e8 as as long as the rook is here you
can't really push the e pawn anywhere
now the upon can be pushed perhaps even
all the way to e5 rook the c1 and now
comes Queen to a5 attacking he carves
Bishop on a3 Queen to b3 pressuring the
f7 pawn you can see that okay at the
moment the Queen is guarding the g5 porn
but maybe an idea is like H for Knights
to g5 will come and then f7 will be
become a weakness at some point and okay
nice to d7 it would be excellent for
black if this night will come to f6 it
will be a very nice defensive piece but
also if white allows it now the knight
is also keeping an eye on e5 so if he 5
is also a possibility we have Bishop to
b4 now attacking the maxims Queen and
here the best choice for black would
either be to go back or to go Queen to
a4 and go for a queen trade and then
after captures captures you will allow
this rope to c7 which is quite
unpleasant but still you can play it now
you can't go back to c6 because of d5
but you can defend the knight or or play
some sort of an active defense we drove
to c8 and then if you lose the beep on
you you can go to rook the c2 and again
have an active game but here Maxime
chose a very dangerous option after he
calls Bishop to b4 he went Queen to f5
and now the Queen doesn't really have
all that many squares sure if you didn't
get Knight to f6 or something maybe you
can free the light squares and then the
Queen can go back if attacked but he
Coronel doesn't allow it Bishop to d3
attacking the Queen Queen to h5 and now
efore and now you can see that the
entire fifth rank is off-limits to the
Queen so the Queen really doesn't have
all that many squares we have e six now
comes h3 taking away even the g4 Square
from the black Queen rook a to d8 and
now comes Luke to e1 we have a five
attacking the bush
the ship goes back and now comes a for
attacking he carves Queen Queen back to
be one and here we could say that it's a
critical moment of the game Black has to
play figure out what to do with this
Queen either play h6 and then play g5 to
maybe maybe create some breathing room
for the Queen and also perhaps the block
the dark square bishop or to go Bishop
to h6 trade of this Bishop immediately
and then freed the dark squares for his
queen but here rook the c8 was played
and now Hikaru has a very nice win here
but it didn't go all the way immediately
but yeah feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the strongest move
for white as we already mentioned that
black really needs to figure out what to
do with the Queen so I will give you a
second a couple of seconds for those of
you who are perhaps interested in taking
a crack at it for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are
very close to winning the entire
Grantchester and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show as we
already mentioned the entire fifth rank
is off-limits to the Queen
now that the bishop is and d2 also the
h6 square is awfully mister the Queen
the g4 square is now off-limits to the
Queen the h4 square so Bishop to e2 now
preparing to create a discovered attack
against the black Queen and there is
very little you can do about to this if
you go Bush of 286 now to try and trade
of the bishop now you can because there
are simply too many discoveries
you could go rook captures on c6 b
captures on c6 and now Knight to g5 and
now after the Queen moves simply g3 and
the Queen is trapped one way to end this
game but after this Bishop to e2 if you
found it once again congratulations
maxime played Bishop to f6 trying to
trying to trying something although like
we said there really isn't anything you
can do here here he Carl could have
played on with with the same idea but
here he actually played rook to d1
so he gave him oxime a moment to breed
but it didn't it didn't really help him
all that much he could have gone for
rook capture
see 6 it would have it would have been
enough or even nice to H 2 again would
an attack on the Queen works just as
well because after the Queen moves let's
say Queen h4 again you eliminate the
bishop rook captures B captures and now
g3 you attack the Queen and now after
Queen captures on h3 which is the only
square available to the Queen Bishop to
g4 will now trap the Queen but ok hikaru
first goes rook to d1 and now we have
rook e - d 8 but black still has no
moves the H v square is such a terrible
square for the Queen that maxime can't
help himself and it's a blitz game
really getting really low on time and
here he Caro goes for it we have Knight
to g5 the Queen is now under attack you
can either go h6 or or you can go h4 h4
seems a little bit better because if you
go h6 you go under the mask of the
bishop on d2 so Queen to h4 but now g3
forcing the Queen all the way to h6 so
no other choice we have Queen to h6 and
now comes Knight captures on f7 by
Nakamura attacking the Queen with a
double attack on the Queen from the
knight and the bishop also the rook is
now under attacked and under attack and
you could bring the Queen back but if
Queen g7 there is no longer any attack
happening and then after Knight captures
on d8 you've just lost an exchange and
you're gonna you're gonna lose this game
very soon so maxime tried Queen captures
on h3 maybe to bring his queen closer to
the attack create some chances but it
doesn't work here Hikaru could have
trapped the Queen immediately with
Bishop to g4 but first he he instantly
played Bishop to f1 he attacked Maxim's
Queen and well there's no escape route
here for the black Queen but still he
gave him at least some hope Queen to h5
and then he repeated Bishop to e2 we
have Queen to h3 and then after a couple
of seconds he saw it not better to f1
but Bishop to g4 and it was actually in
this position unmoved 29 that Maxime for
sure LeGrande the game so Hikaru
Nakamura won not only the London chest
classic but also the grand chess to her
and for this entire event hue
price of 225 thousand dollars and it's
very interesting I already mentioned
this on Twitter Magnus Carlsen as you
all know has won the World Chess
Championship title without winning a
single classical game against Fabiano
Khurana you know in London and now we
have Hikaru Nakamura here winning the
London chess classic by drawing all the
games against the maxime beaugeois Grove
so two two classical's two Rapids three
blitz and only winning one blitz game
and that makes him a winner of the
London Chest Classic and well he already
had a lot of points in the the
Grantchester so now he is the overall
winner of the grand chess to her but
interestingly he also won the entire
Grantchester without winning a single
classical game so I think that's very
interesting to put in perspective of
where chess is now and how you know
engines did their part sort of in in
doing this for four classical chess but
I don't think anything is ruined like
people are saying I mean you still have
to play extreme extreme chess I mean
excellent chess to be able to even get
an opportunity to face your opponent in
the rapid time format or in the blitz
time format so I think it's it brings
you a general picture of how how good a
certain player is and I think after this
event Hikaru Nakamura is now the second
the chess player in the world
I caution is number one in overall
rating it's the URS I don't know what's
it stand for I perhaps the universal
rating system or something but it
combines all of the ratings the
classical the the rapid and the blitz
and then forms a single rating and I
think Nakamura is now second in in that
regard and after Magnus Carlsen but yeah
and in excellent to victory 29 moves you
know the defini maxime beaugeois graph
and also it's very very nice and
interesting also that they are expanding
the Grantchester or so next year they're
they are adding more more places there
the Grantchester will now be played in
four continents and one of the places
where Grantchester
will be held next year is also Croatia
so my country and
it will be a classical event so I'm very
interested in how that whole thing will
work out might also might also be close
to me so might be able to even visit it
should be very nice but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank mikaël Auraria dos santos
diego cheetah Dini darjah Tessa Matthew
sobbing and ever dove with Beltran Pinto
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
videos your thing called for watching
and I will see you soon hopefully with
some more interesting content
I'll see if there are any any more
alpha0 games that I really have to show
and if not and everything is taken care
of then most likely we'll be heading
into capablanca saga until the the world
blitz and rapid championship starts so
thank you all and I will see you soon